how you doing reject nation Greg Alba
here I'm John I'm gonna watch a video
with Johnny today from a channel that I
just love mighty raccoon he does great
or they you would think it's today it
it's raccoon Greg yes so we're gonna
watch and definitive or trailer but
everybody is Deadpool oh boy can't tell
you how many people sent over links of
this one to us well let's check it out
[Music]
what table look at the purple Homer
Simpson
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming love shut off my way already
[Music]
listen up tickets I think the plan is
good except it sucks so let your daddy
DP do the planning in that way it's like
to be really good
[Music]
[Music]
well except Wolverine a lot of Hugh
Jackman
[Music]
I don't give a [ __ ] if they remember you
but really how can they not after 10
years of this [ __ ] Jesus
[Music]
[ __ ] epic music right oh my god
alright that's the end well constructed
well constructed you know what I really
liked about this
he changed the tin to look like the
Deadpool tint of the movie that kind of
have that like blueish look about it
that's color palette and I don't know
that everyone picked up on that but I
had notice that it's like that in every
single shot to make it feel like it's
part of the Deadpool movie yeah so that
was a smart idea or he just did that to
avoid a copyright strike Warnock's in
terms of reference to the Deadpool movie
is a good call on yeah I wonder who did
the voiceover work for this because some
of it's obviously Ryan Reynolds and some
of it is implied by some nails somebody
who knows how to do his distinct alchemy
of like Ryan Reynolds isn't a guy where
I'm like you've got such a distinct
voice anybody convert I say yeah like
good on you for that if there's one
thing this infinity war trailer spoof
does is it makes you want to see
Deadpool in the MCU I know and it makes
you want to see like a bunch of him Fox
and Disney have that deal going and
hopefully this is something what we'll
get yeah I don't know how it would work
but Deadpool of all characters seems
like a guy who can kind of go anywhere
as long as you allow up and himself you
know yeah as long as long as you let him
bring his tone with him I like the crack
about it Kaiba looking like a purple
Homer Simpson because the first time I
saw Thanos I did kind of think of Homer
Simpson oh did you really always like
mouth is and is like the ways chin is
like distinctly kind of differently
textured from the rest of his face
instead the little things I found so
like the thumbs from from Spy Kids
that's what I always does look like a
thumb and I saw someone do like a meme
about it on Instagram later on but yeah
I did think that but this was funny and
it's edited really well good job again
miney raccoon you are master at editing
whoever the hell you people are keep it
up even those handsome
keep it up alright guys well subscribe
to the reject nation and click that
notification bell for the reject nation
looking forward to having you guys be a
part of this world
you